este año se cumplen 19 años de los
atentados contra las torres gemelas el
11 de septiembre y en medio de esta
pandemia las celebraciones como todo lo
que hemos visto este año van a ser de
manera virtual y se podrán seguir por la
mayoría de redes sociales además uno de
los actos más emotivos que es el momento
en el que los familiares de las víctimas
leían sus mensajes
este año será sustituido por unas
lecturas que han sido pre grabadas y que
se dispondrán se podrá escuchar dentro
del museo además uno de los eventos
también más importantes que es justo
cuando dos cañones de luz apuntan al
cielo desde los lugares donde estaban
las torres gemelas en un principio va a
ser cancelados para evitar las
aglomeraciones pero el gobernador del
estado de nueva york andrew como ya
anunció que se va a celebrar se va a
seguir adelante con ese cierre ese
broche final de dos haces de luz
apuntando al cielo para homenajear a las
víctimas fallecidas en el 11-s del 2001
ha dicho que se enviarán los equipos
sanitarios necesarios para que se
respeten las medidas de distanciamiento
social
[Música]
los dos candidatos a la presidencia de
los eeuu donald trump por el partido
republicano quien busca la reelección y
joe bayrén por el partido demócrata
asistirán a el estado de pensilvania
para participar en estos homenajes a las
víctimas que perecieron en los atentados
terroristas del 11 de septiembre se
espera que rindan homenaje a los 40
pasajeros del vuelo número 93 que
perecieron luchando con los
secuestradores para evitar que el avión
según autoridades de los eeuu llegará al
capitolio estadounidense lo que no está
confirmado es si son y bailén estarán al
mismo tiempo participando en este
homenaje
[Música]
para entender el fracaso de la guerra
contra el terrorismo en afganistán en
estos 19 años desde que washington con
la alianza de gran bretaña lanzarán esta
ofensiva contra osama bin-laden la
organización que dirigía al qaeda y los
talibán hay que referirse a los ataques
que suceden diariamente en el país solo
la semana entre el 21 y el 27 de agosto
se dieron 42 ataques que dejaron 117
personas relacionadas con las fuerzas
progubernamentales asesinadas y 37
civiles muertos esta semana hubo un
atentado contra el vicepresidente de la
república del que salió ileso y esto se
da en un momento en el que país va hacia
un acuerdo de paso por lo menos así
pretende hacer en febrero pasado
washington y los talibán firmaron un
acuerdo en el que este país se
compromete a retirar las tropas para el
marzo de 2021 a cambio de que los
talibán entre otras muchas cosas no
dejen que afganistán se convierta en una
sede para al qaeda y el estado islámico
[Música]